guillaume je crois que vous avez une
déclaration d'amour à faire à tamarin
ça mon coeur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'addition vous n'êtes pas comme ça ce
moment où la question pendant une
demi-heure alors même pas 8
alors déjà bébé je vais dire que
je t'ai vu
lundi je n'arrête pas de penser à toi et
je mets ce que tu fais ce week end mais
je vous organise un petit programme en
amoureux en fait j'ai pris ma tease et
un n'étant pas loin de chez moi à
strasbourg un étang voisin est temps
pour faire du pédalo avec many years m
on va faire quelques story instable pour
faire le buzz sur le net les deux et
ensuite moi j'adore j'adore la chine a
dans la gastronomie chinoise
donc
tu ne suis pas sûr qu'elle a envie de
voir ton m
un resto qui s'appelle le bambou
restaurant chinois afin de boer qui
font des spécialités asiatiques
chinoises font un peu tâche 500 mais je
me suis dit qu'on pourrait manger
quelques rouleaux de printemps et après
je pourrais te montrer le meilleur de
moi
je pourrais très bien
avec sa musique de merde
moi ce que je veux savoir tamara c est
ce que tu cherches du sérieux comme moi
ou comme tu l'as dit sur snap un plan
discret avec des hommes gourmands
les surplus malgré ce mariage depuis dix
ans mais non les pas mariés
samarraï mais
c'est comme tous les femmes ici
[Applaudissements]
majolie oui je pense tout ce
qui ressort kate a vécu à aa
allez génial
à temps
non mais tu as marre donc si vous
n'étiez pas en couple est ce que
guillaume aurait peut être être votre
genre de mecs sont voir fond c'est quoi
ce qu'il dit de votre confiance et il
est comment ils ne semblent pas du tout
un peu plus à beaucoup plus âgée paris +
plus ni heures un peu plus plus de
volume
on voit à peu près à peu près la même le
même en plus un peu plus voilà tout est
un peu plus ouais c'est presqu'un
vraiment temps puisqu'on m'a
encore ta vie dans l'eau
qui paraît ta marque en asie les blonds
sont très très appréciée c'est vrai ça
les blondeau l'hérault robert en général
oui oui bah oui mais très appréciée
parce qu'on dit que les aura bien faire
un enfant au radiant c'est le plus
intelligent au monde donc
très attentivement nazis peu importe les
enfants tunisiens
d'amarrage voulez vous dire vous aurez
toujours votre repas dans cette émission
faute superbe ici tout le monde vous
aime d'accord et vous êtes une des plus
grandes beautés qu'ont eue dans cette
émission
est magnifique est-ce que je peux
prochain va parler de choses plus
sérieuses alors oui mais
c'est très bien il ya plusieurs parties
dans cette émission sous les pourparlers
de tout à l'heure l'espion qu'on voulait
venir non tout le monde rêve que je sois
une espionne donc parler avenir tout à
l'heure non je veux pas révéler mon
identité quand même à vous appeler
tarama
martin et ça pendant des heures
et donc voulait venir tout à l'heure
tant qu'il ya plusieurs sujets que je
supportais pas d'accord bas vous allez
arrêter d'être une espionne et oui
je vous dis pas ou si je vous le dis
c'est pas crédible alors elle ne dit pas
ce qu'elle veut pas on va croire que
c'est parce
qu on y
apprend qu'il espère dans les anus
guillaume on peut considérer que c'est
mort non on al'espoir temps l'ami
n'est pas une petite danse à tamara tu
sais danser
non non non quant à lui sur ses terres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci midi
je le dis je me sent désabusés
je n'y crois pas
qu'est ce qui dans ce simulacre à tonton
mecs
n'ont d'yeux d'accord
qu'est ce qu'a pensé de sa danse
si mal un peu coincé devant tout le
monde
surtout chez moi le problème en recevrez
vous
laisse
j'ai vu des expos moment c'est un oui
oui oui mais quand on sait que mathieu
je veux dire que ça dansait on sait ce
qu'on peut vous dire que c'est super